[Music]
tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsey heads to Manhattan Beach
California where he must contend with
the youngest restaurant owner he's ever
encountered how old are you you done 28
she may be an ambitious business school
graduate I didn't really expect it to be
this hard but she may have picked the
wrong business to get into Lisa I am not
serving food like this she's clueless in
the kitchen when was the last time you
looked in this fridge I never really
examined it she doesn't eat the food I'm
actually
vegetarian and she has no control of her
restaurant what are you doing why are
you standing here tonight Chef Ramsey
tries to educate this young owner we're
stilling Tuna on a Monday for Thursday
night but when class begins who will
this owner's immaturity be her downfall
I think you're sure and will the kitchen
staff stick around for graduation day
hell we giving up Sir yeah I know you're
giving up
Lou get ready for a crash course
in restaurant 101 you may have bought
the restant of 23 but you're not running
it grow up Lisa will
[Music]
you just south of Los Angeles is the
picturesque Beach town of Manhattan
Beach 5 years ago Lisa hemt an ambitious
23-year-old fresh out of USC business
school bought a restaurant called Leo D
Manhattan hi guys how are you welcome to
Le did you ever I think I do surprise a
lot of people based on first impression
and seeing someone as young as I am and
female I think they are surprised thanks
for joining us most people still think
that my parents gave it to me or or I
married somebody that gave it to me
which is frustrating but at the same
time I know the
truth I went to USC and study business
entrepreneurship so after I graduated
college I was bound and determined to
only work for myself but instead of
starting from scratch I started looking
at existing businesses with the staff
with customer base and Leo just seemed
like a real great
fit I don't think it looks good like
that one big table Lisa did not at that
time have the experience to run a full
restaurant in my opinion I think we
should separate them the only thing at
that point in time that I believe really
helped this restaurant be success was
that she did have a staff that had been
here forever four one of Fai this is
very smart person but she doesn't have a
lot of experience with restaurant I
don't want to hear complaints I don't
want to hear [__] I just want to hang
out if you see a wine key I took it from
Priscilla a lot of times she gets things
mixed up like she considers me as a
friend not as a employee do you have his
phone
number why are there Morocco they've
been there you put them there on your I
didn't I can't reach that Daman is bar
manager and someone that I have been
kind of dating in the last 6 months
thank you I don't think that I have a
title if she sees something that needs
to be done and we'll ask me to do it
I'll do it are you okay no give me these
just relax I kind of crossed this fuzzy
line where I'm having him work here it's
probably a bad idea but I'm going to do
it
[Music]
anyways it's heartbreaking to me to see
other people choosing other restaurants
around here I struggle with why it's not
busier than it is if aad doesn't change
uh things here I don't think we'll be
open until the beginning of the next
year I've just been so frustrated I'm
barely making it by and um I can't
continue on like
[Music]
this parking lot is jammed so my big
question is what's the problem with the
restaurant I'm about to find
out hello Hi how are you very well how
are you good I'm Lisa henet Lisa nice to
see you do you the owner you're the
owner yeah um so just very quickly
you've owned business for how long I've
been here for 5 years you don't look
that old how old are you if you don't
want ask 28 28 so you got it when you
were 23 how did did you get r at 23 I
was just determined when I graduated
college and you graduated from where USC
Marshal School business yeah was that a
graduation present no dad didn't buy me
a restaurant dad co-signed on a loan for
me and so have a quick by to eat okay
thank you go ahead
and all these colors who come up with
these colors the previous owners came up
with the colors I kind of have kept it
the way it was right what's changed
since you took over from the old
restaurant I haven't changed too much
really um what in 5 years yeah in 5
years so this is the same menu that was
off the previous owners alakar mhm right
the had just name is Luis Martinez and
Lis has been here for 18 years and the
Su Chef is his uro okay good uh what
would you recommend this fillet wrapped
in petta topped with a homemade balsamic
reduction sauce but I'm actually
vegetarian just just say that again
sorry you're yes vegetarian you're
vegetarian yeah right so charal filet
but hold the filet yeah that dish is
awesome thank you wow
bizarre hello hello how are you
Priscilla Priscilla nice beautiful name
server okay nice
thank you Priscilla I think I'm ready S
as the owner is
vegetarian the baked eggplant roll and
then the spicy Ahi Tower please all and
then the jini pasta salad okay yeah
thank you man you're
welcome young man how are you Damian uh
I'm a the bar manager and the catering
director that's a big title catering
director and bar manager all at once
well done is Lisa a good boss Lisa is a
lovely boss yes lovely boss some when
they refer to the boss as being lovely
it sounds like it's an intimate
lovely oh which is's nothing wrong with
it no who is that no I am dating Lisa
yes okay d right that's why she's loved
it got you now
[Music]
okay oh what is that roll really hot
yeah don't you worry thank you um and
these are stuffed with mozzarella cheese
Mozzarella thank you MH oh dear that
look doesn't have very appetizing does
[Music]
it crunchy eggplant undercooked the
eggplants raw that's why it's gone so
black take that back cuz it's like piled
in grease but no problem eggplant
shouldn't be crunchy and oh dear a you
send it back because of the eggplant is
not cooked properly
mother this is the a tower appetizer
thank you ah dear I feel like there's a
firework display taking place on my
plate Rocket
Man something's wrong I can tell on his
face it's so compressed it feels like
it's been done two days
ago ouch spicy eye
tuna that tuna doesn't taste fresh it's
grainy and it's furry here You' been sat
there watching me come
on hey come on no come on I thought it
was going to like some of F I know
that's just gross oh did you like no I
didn't is is it is it frozen tuna no
it's fresh tuna is it yeah I'll bypass
and go to the next one thank you funny
how an owna is not even in the kitchen
you said one mistake two mistakes she's
just standing there hanging out and
chilling out crazy he said that it
tastes like frozen tuna it is frozen
tuna I told him it was fresh here's the
bad news so far not a slim ray of
sunshine not even a glimmer of hope
anywhere on the
food chicken toini pasta salad excellent
good now is that homecooked those are
not homemade ah
[Music]
thanks what is that in there it tastes
like
rubber that is hideous
oh yeah not very pleasant no no I mean
that's just stone cold I'm sorry asked
Lisa to taste the to just the vegetarian
part all right
see I still think it tastes good
everything vegetarian at least I've
tried I love so I think our food tastes
great to me it really does vegetarian
owner Lisa has relied on the Martinez
Brothers hi guys hello come around and a
menu she inherit from the previous owner
and Chef Ramsey was not impressed so
what hurts more than anything was how
bad the food
was I can't think of a worse vegetable
to serve raw and a slice crunchy
[Music]
eggplants why is your restaurant that's
on his ass cooking frozen pasta with a
ship filling and frozen tuna to the
biggest insult well I have to cooking so
are you powerless to talk we talk but we
don't have the power here to make
decisions we don't got the last war
Jesus Christ Lisa come on who runs this
restaurant who's in charge I'm in charge
so you're giving them the permission to
cook like this yeah I guess [__] me I've
had a [__] lunch I'm embarrassed and you
tell me you run the place yeah but you
don't have the initiative to identify
that that [__] why I didn't know you did
didn't know no you don't need a degree
to [__] identify that crap trust me I
think he's being a little over dramatic
we do overall have customers that do
enjoy the food and you tell me you run
the place I guess I didn't think of it
as that horrible or bad you're dreaming
sweetheart coming up that is disgusting
jef Ramsey makes a frighten find filth
we have customers to serve right now and
has to make a dramatic decision you
serve those customers right now I'm out
of here your choice but this time excuse
me he involves the customers are you
interested in being served dinner
without filth then stop a vicious fight
in the kitchen erupts what do you want
what do you mean what do I want as Chef
Ramsey attempts to teach let's clean it
but this young owner refuses to learn
was it really affecting our food tonight
no grow up Lisa will you that's coming
up on Kitchen
Nightmares after an uninspiring lunch
Chef Ramsey is looking for some good
news in tonight's dinner service enjoy
your dinner welcome my name is Daman
I'll be taking care of you tonight I'm
going to go with
Thea Muscat okay sure
[Music]
absolutely um the computers have been an
issue for me from day one uh it's really
outdated the keyboards is not even
working properly so you keep pressing
pressing pressing doesn't
work it's
[Music]
ridiculous my gosh how old is this thing
it's uh I think about 30 years old
everything is coded like numbers for
each and every order that's correct
sometimes all the buttons don't work
Jesus Christ you have a ticket for
108 they don't have a ticket for 108 L
double check if you have my tickets 104
and 105 uh
it's absolute Madness this whole
computerized system is a [__]
nightmare I hate that computer whenever
we kind of busy like really put us
behind the computer just
sucks while an Antiquated ordering
system creates Havoc for the front of
the house and the kitchen Chef Lise
pushes on and manages to get Entre out
to the dining room that the texture is
just completely off I think it's really
gummy why would somebody want to make
that oh no very gummy it's not
gummy I have that back pleas she's right
gummy she's being polite I think the
Lisa doesn't know it know what's going
on with the kitchen what's this here Lou
when was all this done
Monday so we're searing Tuna on a Monday
for Thursday
yeah what are you doing
look at the color of
it get me Lisa please right here I'm
getting really nervous now this is
seared on Monday for Thursday we can't
sear tuna to order that's why it doesn't
taste good does that make business sense
upstairs or it doesn't when was the last
time you looked in this fridge uh I
never really
examined no oh dear Lisa how long ago do
you think that was
sliced I don't know roughly couple of
days couple of days it's like
pastrami but that is
going a like I don't know these things
are going on unless someone tells me and
they haven't told me dinner service is
off to a rough start customers are
unhappy the food is far from fresh and
Lisa the owner is unaware of many of the
problems in her own kitchen
but as bad as it is it's about to get
worse oh my
God that's
disgusting when was the last time this
place was
[Music]
clean stop you
stop everybody
stop Lisa come here 2 seconds come here
when was the last time this place was
cleaned they should be cleaning every
day yeah but look just here just
everywhere disgusting look at it this is
above food I mean come on Louise I am
not serving food like this okay that is
disgusting I don't think it really has
affected or gone in the food like how'
you know we have customers to serve
right now and people do me a favor you
serve those customers right now I'm out
of here your [__] Choice cuz you you
think I'm going to stand there and let
what do you mean what do I
want [__] it I'll do it this way then
excuse
me excuse
me all these tables here can I borrow
for 2 seconds please follow
me sir come through Madam come through I
just stopped serving food in here
because of the [__] and the
dust are you interested in being served
dinner without filth dripping in your
food does anyone to eat
[Music]
now no that's your customers you need me
to tell you
that laugh I'm not laughing I think
you're a jerk you should be
embarrassed excuse
me it's a little bit gross like that but
was it really affecting our food tonight
no like did he need to make a huge
spectacle and embarrassed me in front of
all my customers no Lisa just I'm over
it Lisa what do you mean you come out
make us look like [__] in front of like
friends and
customers Lisa first thing I said can we
stop serving food you're totally
oblivious to what's happening in your
business you may have bought the r of 23
my darling but you're not [__]
running it grow up Lisa will
[Music]
you it's an hour and into dinner service
Chef ramsy has uncovered an unsanitary
situation in the kitchen grow up Lisa
will you and Lisa has escaped to the
bathroom as for the kitchen they're
about to get some much needed Direction
not from the owner but from Gordon than
St clean everybody grab a towel and
start
cleaning the kitchen it's disgusting I
mean we're talking about inches of dirt
it's gross I mean look at this he's
right he's [__] filthy dinner service
is full Forest right now we've got 93
people in the restaurant that need their
food and dinner service is stopped I
don't know what else to do where is Lisa
is she gone upstairs restaurant you did
she in the
restroom look she's in the restroom and
the restroom is in the [__] suling
precious
[Music]
princess it's so upset I can't go out
this we need to face and fix it
can't I have never seen Lisa like that
or upset like that ever she's a very
tough person Lisa you're really strong
of course you can handle
it I didn't expect she was going to
react like this Daman okay that's fine
yeah that's clean yeah yeah it's
cleanest I've ever seen it Lou okay we
start firing up again now yeah yeah is L
out the toilet yet not yet she's still
there she's still in there that's nearly
an
hour
I've been here for an hour hour and 20
minutes I'm not going we've been waiting
too long is she okay is she go to the
bathroom do you want to go and check on
her or I can check on her would you mind
no no
problem L sir let's go I like him I know
what he said he breaks me down like no
one else has me for I can't go outf
she's not going to come out for nothing
we trying really hard so she giv up no
come on BR a dismal dinner service comes
to an end not even an
appetite with disappointed customers
leaving
unsatisfied as for Lisa she finishes off
the service still sequestered in the
[Music]
bathroom I didn't really expect it to be
this hard I try my best and I really
want the best for this restaurant
minutes yes I don't know I feel pretty
helpless right
now so that was a [__] night mhm you got
upset and you disappeared yeah that's
not the way to face problems what was I
supposed to do like what you want me to
go back in dust like I don't get what
you're trying to say right now so is
that the kind of trick that they teach
you in an honest degree to disappear in
a toilet like like a precious
princess I don't think of myself as like
a princess I really don't like just
think I'm am an average person working
hard to fulfill my dreams you bought the
restaurant young that was an easy part
purchasing the hardest part was the
following day running the [__] thing
it's I you know no one's ever told you
the truth but more importantly I think
you're in
denial why am I here because we need
help and I'm missing a key ingredient
obviously because we have a good
location I have a great staff I have a
good energy I I love the
place something's missing okay I'm going
to give you a business assignment
tonight back to the good old days USC I
need five real clear changes that you
want to make tomorrow to be
implemented okay tomorrow New Start
those five issues may start to really
help convince me why you did this 5
years ago
okay good night good night thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you last night Lisa failed her test as a
restaurant owner but today Chef Ramsey
is hoping she will do a better job with
her homework
assignment um right where's Lisa right
here good morning trust you to be in the
bathroom when I came in this
morning
so last night we had a little chat and I
asked Lisa to come up with five
instrumental changes that she wants to
put into this place to make a
significant difference I want to hear
what those are I'll give you one thank
you okay five things that I would like
to change about Leo today M be proud of
the food we're serving keep a clean and
sanitary environment
everywhere the customers should be
impressed by the Ambiance and Decor not
disgusted we need to tighten up the menu
and stay with one theme that works okay
fifth it's more for me to learn how the
kitchen operates yeah good job A+ you've
clearly show me that you know the
problems the hardest thing now is
following it through yes last night was
rock bottom but I think you know I'm
going to have to embrace these changes
and make sure they happen this one issue
that I'm concerned about that you
haven't managed to
tackle in fact let me show you it'll be
easier doing this
[Music]
way POS piece of [__] that is the
biggest headache inside this restaurant
they press less buttons at Nasa
launching astronauts in space I swear to
God
yes
yes stand
back let us do
it when he start to just break the
computer I couldn't believe it I was in
shock that was my dream come true let's
go Lisa let the frustrations
go Priscilla's
I won't drink anymore go go go go
go this is for all the hard time I had
with this piece of [__] I hate it BR
let's
go I hate come on Big Boy let's go don't
hurt yourself I hate this thing
[Music]
okay f with you that felt good well done
coming up there's Mayhem at Le D
Manhattan oh I'm begging just to talk to
each other I'm begging in the kitchen
there's a war of words stop it and then
the cooks resign they're leaving who's
leaving C we giving up bye oh my God
they walked out Lou forcing Gordon to
make a desperate call for help uh listen
I need you right now the tide is rolling
in and this beach restaurant may be too
far underwater to save
while Professor Ramsey is impressed with
Lisa's homework and her intentions for
the restaurant class now continues in
the kitchen where Gordon is ready to
educate Lisa and her chefs so two
changes tonight yes okay very very
simple we'll do a Linguini of crab and
we'll do a t tuna salad Nas okay sounds
good okay so first thing we're going to
see the tuna nice and gently done
yeah is it always cooked at the same
time temperature yeah the better the
quality the least it needs cooking okay
I don't know much about food so I
thought it was extremely exciting and
what an opportunity to watch someone
like Gordon Ramy to go with the tuna Nas
we've got a couple of potatoes on there
it just looks so fresh and flavorful frh
vibrant okay gorgeous done beautiful
right Linguini
yeah why whne in dungeoness Crab in
fresh lime juice right at the very end
yeah it's beautiful
absolutely after a rough first day Lisa
now has a positive attitude and Chef
Ramsey is hoping right let's have a
quick uh briefing she is ready for
another assignment Lisa the boss you're
going to do something you haven't done
in 5 years tonight you yeah here we are
are on the line that's
right yeah you show serious I'm very
serious I'm a little nervous about
hurting myself I hate knives I cut
myself when I was like 3 years old so I
never would have expected to put me on
the line like that I'll see you in a
minute we're opening in 5
minutes hello hi hi like this way your
menu just so you ladies know in addition
to our menu we have few specials Chef
Ramsey has put Lisa in charge of
tonight's specials that's for you apron
perfect he wants her to begin to
understand the inner workings of her
kitchen something she has avoided in the
past definitely came as a shock to me
I'm thinking about the sear I'm going to
have the CB all right thank you very
much folks you're welcome okay there we
go first order ah tuna yeah I didn't
understand what we were doing I was I
was really confused why is this not
turning on Lisa get comfortable with it
yeah yeah get comforable why is this not
turning on this is hot I don't know what
to do with it keep it here was like
touching little things like doing this
oh ouch ow it's hot ow it's hot well
Lisa you got to move
fast wa why is it
[Music]
flaming that's going in the microwave
now yeah why isn't it going there I
think it's a very valid point why is it
going in the microwave why can't it Go
the oven's on yeah yeah it's on can you
see what I'm trying to say it's really
important for you to see this to see a
dish go directly to the microwave I was
just I was really shocked we're not here
spending all this money on microwave
food why would we do that we're so
[__] used to microwaving [__] how do
we flavor out of [__] microwav so
good for you to see this I cannot tell
you it's an hour into dinner service and
while Chef Ramsey specials prepared
capably by Lisa are a hit did you like
it that one's really good the old menu
cooked by the kitchen staff is a blop
bad
fish supposed to be crunchy this is not
worth
$24 T I was crazy I probably had like
seven items send it back I ordered
medium rare which is terrible like no
problem I'll take this back for you no
problem Absolutely I'll throw that right
back on the whe for you right back out
in general the plates going back to the
kitchen was frustrating for me medium
rare please that's rare it seemed like
something went wrong with every one of
my
tables it's overcooked I am very
frustrated what's wrong with that uh
it's overcooked what is that this lamb
is overcooked please refire what
temperature you want medium hey you need
write the temperature that's why well
this is overcooked re fire medum show
you the ticket you never write out the
temperature now I realized that our turo
and Louise like to shift blame all the
time like no one can take
responsibility right on the ticket Okay
so medium please okay we got it we got
it let's go okay we got it can we just
refire it first and we'll argue after
service please everyone is yelling and
being angry it just tears it apart like
you can't do that re fire land
medium thank
you got
it it's overcooked take that back for
you aside from the successful dinner
specials tonight's dinner service has
been a disaster re medium thank you yes
thank you and Chef Ramsey is looking for
someone to take control stop it okay
we're going to make it right now sorry
guys thank you how's that Port coming 6
minutes 6 minutes two AI towers and one
calamari right Lisa you in control now
yeah yeah good let's go pass Us in the
window there it is yes got it up on I
feel like once I kind of learned my
dishes I was like come on what's next
what's next let's get it together 127
yes go amazing very tasty very fresh
it's good it's really good what's going
on now it's vital to know what's going
on in the kitchen as a owner operator I
should have done years ago and thank you
for coming out and hopefully we see you
again
[Music]
soon okay tonight you're good thank you
but here's the bad news I can't think of
a worse scenario than having lazy chefs
it is the quickest way of closing down a
business I'm willing to work with Arturo
and Lis but just everything has to
[Music]
change Lisa's ability to change has
inspired Chef Ramsey to implement a
change of his own a drastic remodel of
Leo that he and his team work through
the night to
[Music]
complete good morning good morning today
big day Leo is is relaunching ready yes
do it yes yes time to see the new Leo
let's
go come in come in come
in come in come in come in come in come
over oh my God it's beautiful first
thing that herenda wall that was
dividing your restaurant has gone now
the whole thing just fills open easier
to get round W look oh that's so cool
new seating brand new Bonet check out
the new China no more hideous colors all
the plates and all the little small bits
of China were from webst straw I was
totally speechless I love what they did
with the curtains with the lighting with
the pictures one thing this area hasn't
got and one thing you've got every
chance of succeeding in is becoming
Manhattan's yeah local cool Wine Bar
serving great food great Wines By the
glasses more importantly a very cool
place to hang out I think think a wine
bar is exactly what Manhattan Beach
needed there's no place out there around
here that has that one more little
surprise you've got to see these the
system before was useless this is
phenomenal I'm so happy right now wow I
was so surprised when I saw the new
system no way I couldn't believe it I
was in shock this is designed by Halo
it's the most advanced restaurant POS
system anywhere in the world w wow I
believe in you I believe in the staff
you've got to pull this off we will oh
definitely we have
to not only will the new Decor be on
display tonight Chef Ramsey has
overhauled the food and designed an
exciting wine friendly menu for what he
is hoping will be the new Hot Spot in
Manhattan Beach wow it's a lot of food
that's so pretty let's start off from
the top the homemade chicken sausage
grilled baby archo Vegetarian Delight
one of my favorites flat breads they are
fantastic you've got a chance to gain a
serious reputation mhm right Onre your
burger grilled minute steak I think it's
going to be a huge hit here I love the
new menu it's so tasty it's easy and I
think it's
[Music]
perfect despite a poor performance last
evening Lisa is hoping her kitchen staff
are motivated by the changes and that
they will rise to the occasion for the
most important nights in Leo's history
one 2 three
Le do
it welcome to the new le thank you enjoy
some wine tonight yeah that's right we
will this is our new menu we have some
new appetizers also okay how would you
like that to be cooked I have that rare
food
yeah I'm nervous I'm so happy with this
computer
okay we're going guys yes yes
concentrate guys
yeah 20 minutes Lou I need some stuff
coming out here guys H think this
there's tickets piled in the kitchen oh
Jesus in spite of a new ordering system
30 minutes into service no Entre have
left the kitchen and there appears to be
a communication breakdown what's
happening here no one's even working
together it starts off from the chef
calling out the order away now one scet
one Pini one p one grilled State nobody
answers
me yes yeah yes sir yeah I'm begging
just to talk to each other I'm begging
about the [__] menu being put up
together collectively at the same time
that's what's not
happening I was a little nervous right
then because with my relaunch I really
wanted to run smooth unfortunately
there's no communication it's
awful unbelievable dining room looks
absolutely beautiful fine great granted
but the kitchen an absolute [__]
disaster five headless chickens with not
an ounce of leadership qualities right
now I'm depending on a 208y old lady to
save her Resturant the biggest test of
having career so
far okay 60 minutes into service the
kitchen staff is finally communicating
and sending out Entre however they are
not being well received by the dining
room are you serious all the
113 I need 115 and 60 all of these
steaks are called oh come on guys what
the [__] they're overcooked as
well listen to me when a minute steak is
cooked it's got to be surfed straight
away you can't hold a minute steak three
steaks on the fly as quick as you can
when people are getting their food
they're getting undercooked overcooked
still sending it back they want the
whole new steak [__] hell there's
more food going in the [__] trash
than there is going on the [__] tabl
we either need our food like 5 minutes
or our check 90 minutes into relaunch
diners are fed up with not being fed so
if you don't want to wait and Lisa is
desperate for her kitchen to bounce back
oh my gosh look at
that those are the ticket oh Jesus they
don't know what the [__] they're doing
are you kidding me right now this is
ridiculous like I just couldn't believe
the the ignorance back there what are
you doing why aren't you making food why
are you standing here you're just
looking at tickets make some [__]
food I don't understand please Ur will
you please tell her to make some food
I'm trying right now I'm doing my stuff
too this is
stupid they just all standing there
they're not doing anything I getting
paid
as
D
I'm you know we're out of here we're
we're out of this [__] yeah we can take
it anymore h no no they're they're
leaving H who's leaving why oh my God
hello we're giving up bye too we're
giving up sir I know you giving up
why why is this what they do Louie Louie
on my biggest night they walked out
please guys l
[Music]
I'm they're they're leaving who's
leaving we giving out we giving out bye
oh my God it's relaunch night at Leos
and the only thing that's taken off is
the kitchen staff Lou
Lou please guys for them to walk out
like that with all those tickets like I
wasn't sure what to do or what to expect
the head sh I'll yeah fails out that's
[__]
[Music]
finess hello Scot Gordon uh listen I
need you right now jump in the car and
get down here quickly will you
[Music]
please Lisa I just phon Scott I told him
to jump in his car and he's getting down
here Chef Scott's been my right-and man
for the Last 5 Years okay I've asked him
to be here as your consultant for the
next month to oversee this [__] place
is he going to jump on the service and
get this place up to speed we cannot
afford to let this place go down no
chance with an empty kitchen and a full
dining room relaunch night at Leo is
heading towards disaster I don't even
know what to do even though Chef Scott
is on his way they're all running away
like cowards Gordon makes one more
attempt to get the disgruntled kitchen
staff back hey Lou yeah we need you Lou
you coming back this is music to my ears
I I would think thank you a
too okay Scott yeah AO look Scott's here
yeah look he's here to help let's lift
it up and let's let's let's get this
back together yes okay okay here we go
listen up everybody I need a Pudo pizza
in the oven I need one Margarita barbecu
chicken I need a lamb sandwich up top
right now to see Scott in the kitchen
like take command the way he did that
shows what a head chef should be doing
hey is that pjo pizza in the oven okay
how on 3 minutes 4 minutes 3 minutes I
saw a communication I'd never seen in
that kitchen before with Scott at the
rains okay let's pick up oural rosemary
chicken steak medium rare gome with the
Pudo Pizza table 106 thank you y cheff
Scott helped the kitchen make a massive
comeback I have a clam two Tartar and
asparagus key and the evening ended
successfully wow how's your steak
excellent I think tonight overall was a
good learning
experience thank you guys okay and near
my last table serve tonight so I'm
looking forward to talking with Gordon
about what I should do and moving
forward with this restaurant because we
really really need a solid kitchen
staff okay Lisa honestly you have
seriously grown up this week more than I
ever expected to do you show such
commitment you do your homework you show
up on time and more importantly you are
a very fast learner however it's not the
same with the team your kitchen staff in
a norm situation would have been
expelled then walking out like that in
the middle of the service was disgusting
I 100% agree that was horrible your
dream effectively is in their hands I so
disappointed tonight I can't put up with
that [__] I'm not sure whether Lis and
Arturo are going to be part of the new
Leo but now that I I have a much better
understanding from Gordon I am going to
really Embrace these changes and make
this place successful I am so impressed
with the way you've handled what you've
had to do in this short period of time
you stay in control and you hold the
reins firmly I seriously believe in you
thank you I can't wait to come back I
can't wait to have you back I'll be your
honor student when Gordon walks back in
here whenever he comes back in months
from now and sees this restaurant
buzzing that's going to be my proudest
moment good night while am I done than
you so much good luck spend time in that
kitchen will okay good thank
you tonight was actually the first night
this place felt like Lisa's Restaurant
sadly there are still leftovers from the
past that keep on dragging her down and
for her to move on and be a success she
has to drop her excess baggage and move
on what the [__] was on in that bathroom
[Music]
after Gordon left in the days that
followed Scott took the next few weeks
to train a newly motivated Louis in
aruro that's for the clams and muscles
yeah okay keep it here yeah that's fine
no problem welcome to the new Leo and
with Lisa's Newfound kitchen expertise
from now on 100% just come straight to
me I can listen and make changes
Manhattan Beach's newest wine bar has
seen a boost in Revenue I learned so
much from Gordon Ramsey the whole
experience has been amazing like it's
it's lifechanging really this man has
given us everything all the tools in the
world like a dream come true now let's
do it I really feel like I do own the
role of being the restaurant owner
[Music]
now